400 meters long and weighing
200 000 tons stuck in what's often
described as the most important shipping
lane in the world
a maritime accident with global
implications
the ever-given container ship became
wedged across the suez canal on tuesday
when high winds blew her off course
about 12 percent of global trade passes
through the 193 kilometer long canal
which connects the red sea with the
mediterranean providing the shortest
link
between asia and europe the vessel
carrying around 20 000 containers is
registered in panama
operated by taiwanese transport company
evergreen marine
it was sailing from china to the port
city of rotterdam in the netherlands
when it got stuck the japanese owner has
apologized but says the situation is
extremely difficult
at present the traffic along the space
canal has been disrupted due to the
incident
and local authorities are working on
resolving the issue using tugboats
but there is no estimated time for it to
be resolved
this image posted on a ship tracking
website shows the backlog of at least
150 vessels
stuck in the northern entrance of the
canal at port saeed
in the middle in an area called the
bitter lakes and at the southern
entrance
at sewers the vast majority of oil from
the gulf is transported to europe along
the canal
oil prices rose sharply on thursday
industry experts a warning of a flood of
insurance claims covering the vast
amount of cargo being held up
including automotive parts and consumer
goods the economic
implications are as you said in the
billions of dollars
and it's more complicated as things
stand because
a lot of the losses are delay losses
without physical damage
that implies implicates particular
admiralty rules
that may prevent innocent parties from
recovering their damages from the ship
owners
egyptian officials say at least eight
tugboats are trying to dislodge the
vessel
which experts say could take days if not
weeks
containers may have to be offloaded in
order to lessen the weight
ships now face the prospect of having to
travel thousands of additional
kilometers around the southern tip of
africa
a huge cost and potentially delaying
delivery of goods by weeks
it's a cork in a bottle and there's no
way to go and as you've described the
ships that are stuck
uh throughout the canal and at the north
end uh
are in a precarious position and they
may not be able
just to turn around and take another
course as long
as it and expensive as it is to go from
the mediterranean around
africa and vice versa the suez canal
authority says around
20 000 ships passed through the canal
last year
earning egypt billions of dollars in
total fee
revenue the ever given is one of the
largest container ships in the world but
for every hour
and every day it remains stuck on a reef
and stationary
there are concerns about the financial
fallout and impact
on global trade charles stratford al
jazeera
very pleased to have james moran with us
now an economist former eu ambassador to
egypt
jordan and yemen as well and an
associate senior research fellow at the
center
for european policy studies with us from
brussels today great to have you
with us there is that phrase which we
use in life sometimes saying it's like
trying to turn an oil tanker around no
cargo ship this time obviously but
that's what it's like isn't it this is
not a situation where we can just
if it was airlines you could say right
we ground flights here we redirect them
here
and we can get on with it this is a
really slow turnaround
yeah and it's uh as you can see as your
reporter just
brought out it's an incredibly
complicated uh
technical challenge that lies before the
uh suicidal authority and everybody else
involved in getting this thing
back on the water and it's going to take
some time i think it's important
uh what the salvage company uh has been
saying which has been very cautious
about the time it's going to take to
right
this ship and it could well be a few
days but a few days of course is very
very costly
uh each day um people have made
estimates of between eight ten billion
uh dollars of trade going through the
suez canal absolutely fundamental for
european supply chains it's not just
about oil
it's just as important the um the goods
coming from the far east china and so on
china number one partner for trade with
the european union and most of the stuff
goes through the sewers canal
not without president james the canal
has been closed previously when it was
nationalized when the arab-israeli
war happened i guess it's just a
different world now in that you have
ships that are so much bigger than they
were then
so much more trade happening around and
as we see this was an accident it could
happen at any time how do you mitigate
against that
well i don't know i mean one thing
that's very important not for now but
once the uh the situation is resolved
and actually it will be we take time
uh there will be a need for a very
thorough
transparent international investigation
into what happened was it the weather
uh was it uh was it the problem on the
ship itself with his engines was it
the sewers canal authority of course
don't forget that the ships that go
through the canal around the authority
of pilots
provided by the sca a whole series of
possibilities are there
as to explain why it happened but to
make sure it doesn't happen again
uh that will be very very important and
it will not be an easy thing to do
um an international investigation in
something like this will be a challenge
for everyone including the egyptian
authorities don't forget
and you just mentioned the history of
the suez canal yeah the suez canal is an
iconic
uh symbol of egyptian independence so it
will take some time
yes so can i ask you to zero in on egypt
a bit more obviously you've told us
about the
wider implications but the importance
the economic importance the
employment all of these things to egypt
itself
yeah there are two main aspects for
egypt one of the revenues they get
uh from the past ships through the canal
which are worth
up to six billion dollars a year which i
think is the third or possibly the
fourth
most important source of foreign
exchange for egypt
and the second part of it is of course
the developments that have been taking
place around the canal area
uh the suez canal uh free zone uh where
you've had a number of investments
especially from china and elsewhere
in the last few years in from companies
who are
wanting to take advantage of the
strategic position
of the canal and the european market on
the other side
so they employ a lot of people thousands
of people are working there and you have
many people working at the canal
authority as well
all of these jobs um are not at risk
but they're certainly extremely
important for the well-being of
egypt yeah it's just a fascinating story
isn't it playing out in front of us
almost in slow motion
james moran thank you for joining us
thank you
thank you